hey folks welcome to kpop breaking news
Daniel Dwyer here Justin there's a bunch
of xbox one leaks coming out it's like a
big Xbox one balloon and people are just
poking holes in it and it's going
everywhere and the first off is come
from GAF telling me about net kernel and
the rumors that are kind of being
churned around there now of course you
have to take all of this with a huge
grain of salt none of this is confirmed
by Microsoft they do not comment on
rumors and speculation but according to
gaff there's going to be a price drop
coming for the the xbox one you know
also possibly a white console possibly a
diskless drive one there will be no
blu-ray drive in your xbox one and some
people are speculating that maybe that's
going to lead to this new lower price
one but you'll get a 399 dollar xbox one
and it's not gonna have a disk drive
it's only gonna have a maybe a one
terabyte hard drive hmm it's not
something that would make you want to
buy it like not having to describe I
find it funny that this is that this is
the conversation that's happened that we
were already bought like three months
I've and the launches console and
already to trial it if this is true it
seems crazy they're trying to drop the
price because presumably for whatever
reason people are maybe adopting it well
the PlayStation 4 is a hundred dollars
today I mean they do need to compete
with the PlayStation 4 on price and as
we've seen the PlayStation 4 is is out
selling it by a little bit so what I
want to consult it does not this drive
presumably like all that stuff is day
one digital so perhaps i bought call it
Judy on my xbox one and they digitally
just downloaded no problem and I don't
really watch that many blu rays anymore
we've all got netflix and stuff like
that so yeah I can see that being a
benefit to tighten for one to lead the
pictures that have come out that looks
pretty sick that looks good too I love
the idea but at the same time having to
wait eight hours to download you know 80
gigabyte game when it comes up that
doesn't seem so awesome yeah downloading
and installing it and whatnot those
games are quite big in comparison to
what we've had like previous gen as well
and it's surprising that the rumor isn't
that they're gonna get rid of kynect
which is you know what everyone's been
calling for like what I don't use Kinect
for anything right now I'd like my xbox
one without the Kinect i would pay a
hundred dollars less to get that and
since launch that seems to be the
argument a lot of people had is that it
wouldn't be so expensive we wouldn't
feel labored with this extra piece of
technology that even so like how often
do you use
connect on your xbox one like it just
never happens and there's been a lot of
load of other leaks that have come out
around this around this price drop stuff
including halo and yes a halo 2
anniversary edition some people are
confirming that there's gonna be
crackdown 3 announcement at e3 sunset
overdrive it got some dates I mean of
course again all of these are just
rumors we have no idea who the actual
source for this is VG 24-7 said that
they collaborated with another source
also unlisted no idea who these guys are
but the society over there just tell
them that I didn't get some friends in
Microsoft clearly or and I have a friend
at Microsoft who's confirmed that the
next Xbox is going to be a hologram oh
really you heard it here first so what
do you think about this these
revelations is price drop stuff like if
this let's hypothesize let's just say
this is actually going to happen at what
stage does this type of information get
released is this like a is this normal
as rumors I'll just flutter out into the
ether is this something that would
happen to d3 is this something that
happen Microsoft before e3 so that they
can concentrate on games at e3 or where
do what did you go tell you about from a
business side like this is obviously
very early they're probably I'm sure
they're considering it Xbox one is or
the ps4 is a hundred dollars cheaper
there are some steam machines who you
know they if they commanded a good price
like those could be huge competitors and
Microsoft has to be thinking about that
so this isn't necessarily an
announcement that's going to happen but
I'm sure it's part of internal talks and
internal debates about how can we
compete against these other guys and if
we do hear about it this is going to be
a bombshell that would come out at e3
yeah like I'm sure they didn't want it
to be this early but the fact that
they're talking about really isn't that
surprising like of course you're talking
about it you're you're competing against
all these other guys how are you gonna
beat them those are talks to Microsoft
has to be having here's an idea of a
head to beat them release some games
next thing let's get some games
goddammit a for continuing coverage of
the next-gen consoles and everything on
all the rumors that are being spread
around gaff and all over the internet
and make sure you keep right here on
gamespot com
you